in hamburg at the bernhard knocked
institute for tropical medicine
scientists are studying mosquitoes that
transmit the dengue virus
some of the insects come from brazil
they're kept in incubators at a constant
temperature of 25 degrees celsius
the researchers have developed a method
of separating mosquitoes that carry the
pathogen from those that do not
they've been collaborating on the
project with the federal university of
rio de janeiro
our goal is to produce a map ahead of
the 2016 olympics that shows the
dangerous areas
so we can say
here the mosquitoes are more likely to
carry dengue
then we can combat them in a more
targeted manner
in the high security lab the scientists
also infect mosquitoes with the dengue
virus
they want to find out which of the
insects are particularly susceptible to
the virus
and how fast the virus
spreads to catch the mosquitoes in
brazil more effectively the researchers
use a special trap
it contains substances that attract the
species that transmit dengue
which of the trapped insects are
actually infected with the virus
that's shown by an automatic test run by
this machine that the scientists have
developed
the analysis takes just two hours the
test shows that this sample is infected
the method can also be used to test for
dengue virus in humans